hello everyone my name is amina mansour
and i'm a solutions architect at google
cloud
scott service who's the global container
engineering lead at hsbc will be joining
me later for a q a
with the growing interest and adoption
of hybrid and multi-cloud architectures
i find myself working with a lot of
customers that are looking for guidance
on architecting their platforms and
choosing where their applications and
services reside
today we will briefly review the
difference between hybrid and
multi-cloud
then i will present some of the more
common patterns we've seen with our
customers
and for the interesting part of the talk
we will have a q a with scott to share
his experience and insights with hybrid
and multi-cloud
so what is the difference between hybrid
and multi-cloud
if we take hybrid first this is where
you have workloads that are deployed
across multiple environments
one being a private on-prem data center
and one in the public cloud
multi-cloud on the other hand combines
at least two public cloud environments
but you can also have a private
computing environment as part of your
multi-cloud setup
so really multi-cloud is a superset of
hybrid cloud
we can put these patterns into two
buckets
the first is distributed deployment
where the aim is to run the application
in the environment that suits it best so
each application runs in a specific
environment
the second is redundant deployment where
you deploy the same application in
multiple environments
let's now look at the different patterns
the first pattern we will talk about is
the tiered or layered pattern
the idea of it is to focus first on
deploying front-end applications to the
public cloud
in this pattern you keep your back-end
applications and data in the private
computing environment
some advantages are that this allows you
to start with the less complex
migrations you also benefit from what
google cloud knows what to do well so
things like load balancing and auto
scaling
and you're keeping your data and
backhand on-prem for regulatory reasons
because you are communicating across
environments choose the google cloud
regions and interconnect location
closest to your data center
make sure to secure the communication
with vpn tunnels tls or both
and establish a common identity between
environments to authenticate across
the second pattern is the partition
pattern
combines multiple public cloud
environments that gives you the
flexibility to deploy an application in
the best computing environment for it
so application a is on cloud one and
application b is on cloud two
based on its dependencies and cloud
services it uses
because of your presence in multiple
public cloud environments you're
lowering your risk and you have the
flexibility to change plans or
partnerships
you can also choose which provider to
run an application or service on
depending on its needs
each additional environment comes with
additional overhead so weigh the
advantages against the overhead
you should also minimize dependencies
across clouds so it doesn't affect
performance
and focus less on portability of your
applications and more on the portability
of your workflows and having a unified
platform across providers
our third pattern is edge
running workloads in the cloud requires
that clients have fast and reliable
internet connectivity
there are scenarios when you are not
relying on continuous connectivity such
as stores or supermarkets that might be
only connected occasionally or use links
that are not reliable enough for
business critical transactions
with this pattern you run time and
business critical workloads locally at
the edge of the network while using the
cloud for all other kinds of workloads
in an edge setup the internet link is a
non-critical component that is used for
management purposes and to synchronize
or upload data
this helps you ensure low latency and
self-sufficiency in cases when you
cannot do that due to network
restrictions
you also reuse existing investments and
equipment at those edge locations
and remember that ingress traffic to
google cloud is free so that makes it
easier to communicate back to the cloud
with status or data syncs
two things to keep in mind with this
pattern you don't want to increase the
burden of management of these edge
locations linearly with how many they
are
so you should have a centralized control
plane in the cloud to manage them all
also the less dependencies on the cloud
environment the more reliable and faster
your edge setup is
our fourth pattern is analytics
in this pattern transactional workloads
stay on prem and analytics workloads are
in the public cloud to leverage best of
grade services
of course the first thing that comes to
mind with this pattern is bigquery which
is a very common reason why our
customers choose this pattern
analytics workloads often need to
process huge amounts of data and can be
bursty so they lend themselves well to
the public cloud and you don't need to
over provision on-prem anymore
google cloud also provides a rich set of
services to manage data throughout its
entire lifecycle ranging from initial
acquisition through processing and
analyzing to final visualization
also you get to take advantage of cloud
capabilities again like i mentioned
ingress traffic and moving data from the
private computing environment to google
cloud is free of charge
and when you have existing hadoop or
spark workloads consider migrating jobs
to dataproc and migrating existing hdfs
data to cloud storage
use cues to hand over data so things
like pub sub or maybe even cloud storage
buckets to hand over the data to google
cloud
choose a transfer approach that is best
suited for your data set size and
available bandwidth for the initial data
transfer
and you should use consistent tooling
and processes across environments to
help increase your operational
efficiency
this one is very common for a majority
of the patterns
last but not least is the bursting
pattern and it's the only pattern
discussed today that fits in the
redundant deployment pattern bucket
the idea of the cloud bursting pattern
is to use a private computing
environment for the baseline load
and burst to the cloud temporarily when
you need that extra capacity
while you can accommodate bursty
workloads in a classic data center-based
computing environment
by over-provisioning your resources this
approach is not really cost-effective
so this pattern allows you
to apply it to interactive and batch
workloads but when you're dealing with
interactive workloads you must determine
how to distribute requests across
environments
these three advantages are all related
it allows you to reuse or in this case
use your investments
and there is no longer a need to over
provision your computer resources
on-prem so that enables increased
utilization and cost-effectiveness in
the private computing environment
as for best practices again you should
choose the regions that are close
together that applies to the cloud
region and the interconnect location
you should make cloud resources private
for batch workloads those are not public
facing and so in this case you should
secure and have them be private and you
should secure the communication because
the data that is exchanged between
environments might be sensitive
and finally establish common identity so
that you can securely authenticate
across environment boundaries
now it's time for the more interesting
part of our session
scott is the global container
engineering lead at hsbc and the global
anthos product owner he's also a google
cloud certified fellow and co-chair of
the cncf financial services working
group
great to have you with us here today
scott
hi amina thanks for having me
before we start with our questions why
don't you tell us a little bit about the
scale of hsbc
sure
so before we get into the patterns i'll
explain about who hsbc is we are one of
the world's largest global banks
and the sheer scale of what we deal with
on a daily basis is presented in this
slide
as you can see we're in 66 countries
we process about 1.5 trillion dollars a
day in payments
we have 110 000 servers roughly globally
right now so that's an out-of-date
portion we have data centers in 21
different countries that does not count
where we have large server rooms as well
we have a
large amount of employees around 235 000
we've got 39 million customers globally
we process about revenue of 53.8 billion
a year
and we have offices all over the world
roughly about 3 900 offices so it's a
large organization and even in the i.t
section we have 40 000 i.t professional
work for us
thank you for that intro scott
let me start by asking you why you would
consider a hybrid or multi-cloud
solution in a highly regulated industry
definitely definitely great idea the
first one i'll talk about is going to be
the hybrid cloud
so in the hybrid cloud as we have on the
slide we have data centers globally and
again we have server rooms globally as
well so we have a large investment
in data centers already so we want to
utilize that where we can but of course
going to the cloud makes sense in
multiple scenarios so to use these data
centers we have a hybrid cloud solution
it helps us with a back out plan so if
we go to a cloud with an application we
have to have a backup plan for the
regulators so we have to show that if
something were to go wrong in the links
the relationship
uh just with the vendor in general where
do we go from there and on-prem is a
viable solution it also could go to
another csp
but since we have those data centers we
can leverage that internally
finally it takes time to get approval to
go to the cloud for an application it
can take three to six months
now in that time
you don't want to sit idle you might
want to refactor your app you might want
to test out some new services so with
the introduction of containers
uh kubernetes and anthos for on-prem if
a workload fits into that
my developers can actually start
developing that today
and they can move that to the cloud once
they have the approval to do so
in the multi-cloud side
we select the best of breed for free
features
for each csp
as you said bigquery is a big one for
the google side and it's just one of
many different features on the google
site
there's also regional availability
certain times i have an application has
to go into multiple regions
but somebody like google may not have a
presence in china
or you may not have a point of presence
somewhere close to a certain other
region so we have to go multi-cloud
where it makes sense to go multi-cloud
those are all great reasons scott of
course you recognize there are many
other reasons for other industries and
verticals but of those patterns that i
described which patterns are you most
likely to implement
sure all the models are great all the
patterns are great so the first one that
i like to talk about is going to be the
the tiered
model or the tier pattern
so
in my previous days we would have our
websites on site and we would be under
attack we have denial of service attacks
we have to engage multiple teams
operating systems networking
obviously our service providers
and we would spend hours and hours
trying to
remediate that situation we want to
restore the services to our customers
and our employees
so rather than have us deal with that
the whole time we're fighting that fire
we are not innovating and we're not
going forward for the business
so let's let somebody like google who
was born in the cloud raised in the
cloud knows the cloud and can protect
the cloud we will put our presentation
layer in gcp
and products like the web application
firewall available on app armor or cloud
armor
would help us to remediate that attack a
lot faster and not drain our resources
so put the front end in the csp but
keeping your data safe
and even better regulatory compliance to
heavy data on-prem
the other model would be the partition
model
now we've already mentioned that hsbc
has multiple data centers and multiple
server rooms globally so we have a heavy
investment in machines
but what about the bursting pattern from
your experience what are some use cases
for that
yeah the bursting pattern is a great use
case for cloud however it's also one of
the more difficult ones to utilize and i
say that because the challenge is the
regulatory issues that we deal with in
this industry
so because of that i can't just select
any workload and say okay i'm going to
burst when i need to in the cloud it has
to be an application that is approved
the data has to be approved so we have
to be careful
so with the right choice it's the it's a
perfect scenario for the challenges that
it addresses
and 2020 was one of those challenges
so of course during 2020 a lot of people
started working from home basically
everybody started working from home
if you had to expand your data center
for certain use cases because of this
different working pattern you might have
to expand out and scale out your server
infrastructure that was a big challenge
in 2020 trying to order equipment was
delayed for months due to manufacturing
due to shipping
or due to silicone shortages
so we can't wait months for that
so to address this bursting is the
perfect scenario it's a little bit
longer than normal temporary kind of
like we were mentioning during your
introduction but at some point we do
hope that all of this is going to
die down everything's going to be good
and then we all get back to the office
we don't need all that extra capacity so
by scaling up and bursting into the
cloud
we do it faster we do it cheaper and we
don't have any of that hardware left
over
after we're done
with all of the nightmares 2020.
100 you hit the nail on the head with
this example but let's pivot to
something happier what's a fun use case
for the edge pattern
yeah the edge pattern is one i've always
liked uh so in the banking industry a
lot of processes a lot of hardware
starting to look at that so atms
we're not quite there yet but that's a
great use case for an edge from an hsbc
view though
the edge case i like to bring up is
something called pepper
pepper is actually a robot uh originally
developed by softbank that we have in 22
branches
and what pepper does is it'll greet the
customer as they come in
so banking isn't exciting we all kind of
know that pepper makes it exciting
so when you walk into this branch and
you see this robot with a really cute
face looking at you with a lcd and
touchscreen you can walk up to her and
you can choose what you want to talk
about to csr
or what you what products you might be
interested in
not only is it fun and interactive but
it cuts the wait time down for the
customer this all goes into a system
that the csrs will see and then they can
walk out to get you and know exactly
what you need
before four other people ask you the
same questions
you go right to the person they know
what you need and they can process your
request
really quick
now aside from the cool factor it does
bring people into the branch so people
want to see pepper taking pictures
posting them we get our brand out there
but it can go further than just this
basic stuff so internally pepper is
limited to about four core atom
processor with four gigs of ram you can
do a lot of processing
it can talk to systems locally so we can
figure out what we need for you
but to make it more fun and to expand it
we can connect that into the cloud
so of course using something like google
we can use translation services
uh enhanced text text to speech
ai interactions and one of my favorite
ones that we've been debating with
consent
would be facial recognition
so pepper can greet you when you walk
into the branch and they can say welcome
back amina would you like to look at
this service or just having a
conversation with you using the ai
interaction
that's amazing i personally hope to meet
pepper someday
i know that hsbc leverages bigquery for
some analytics workloads so tell us a
little bit more about the analytics
pattern there
yep we're a bank we've got a lot of data
we have a lot of things that we have to
sift through look at
you know do analysis on so bigquery is
very popular among our developers and
that's at a global scale
so with bigquery
as you said during the introductions it
just it can process your data
to handle millions of queries per second
and without us having to expand and
install hardware for this now in the
earlier days we used to do this we would
run things that would take two weeks it
would run out a bunch of kit that we
also had dr for because if we didn't
have a problem with prod we'd have to go
to dr it's a lot of money that when
you're not processing anything it just
sits there
so aside from just being slower and
costing more
we wanted to go to the cloud for that
so one of our applications that we did
happen to move used to take about 10
days to process the information
it sat on a lot of kit and for the rest
of that month
it just sat
so it takes up power
it takes up cooling
um it just takes up general maintenance
we have to pay for a lot of stuff that
isn't in use
by moving it over to bigquery
we only utilize or really get charged
when we're utilizing it
it also cut our processing time on that
operation from those 10 days down to
less than a day
and a certain operation down to a couple
of hours
so we get the information analyzed much
quicker
and cheaper and there really is nothing
better than faster and cheaper and it's
done well
that's a great use case for bigquery and
the analytics pattern
thank you so much for joining us today
scott it is great to learn about all the
innovation that google cloud products
enable for our customers
great thanks i mean it was my pleasure
to be here
if you'd like to continue learning more
about the different multi-cloud and
hybrid patterns and how to implement
those using google cloud products
please check out these sessions here
that will talk about anthos for example
as the control plane supporting that
multi-cloud or hybrid patterns
as well as different examples with cloud
run running and hybrid and multi-cloud
environments all the way to extending
your anthos or
multi-cloud environment to vm workloads
on-premises as well
thank you so much for joining the
session today and hopefully it was
useful
you